[Musique]
les produits de marque maison ou marqué
privé gagnent en popularité vendu
généralement à plus bas prix que ceux
des marques nationales vous vous
demandez si la qualité de leurs
ingrédients est au rendez-vous
[Musique]
une perception qui existe depuis très
longtemps en fait et qui persiste depuis
au moins une vingtaine d'années les
produits de marque maison sont moins
chers voire parfois significativement
moins cher que leur équivalent en marque
national donc ça nous donne
effectivement une impression que la
qualité est pas là la raison numéro un
qui justifie cette différence de prix là
ce sont les conditions commerciales oui
la qualité est là aujourd'hui la marque
privée joue un rôle est un produit
comparable à la marque nationale avoir
une marque nationale c'est beaucoup
d'investissements au niveau du marketing
au niveau du développement de produits
au niveau du contrôle qualité au niveau
du service à la clientèle qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont des coûts supplémentaires qui se
retrouvent sur le produit évidemment
nous les marques privées toutes ces
économies là on les fait et ça nous
permet d'avoir des produits qui sont
appris raisonnables jour après jour nous
avons demandé à la nutritionniste
Isabelle marquis de comparer les valeurs
nutritives et les listes d'ingrédients
de produits d'entrée de gamme de trois
marques maison
de sobexigéa son nom de Provigo loblases
et sélection de métro à la marque
nationale de référence
c'est faux de croire que les produits de
marque maison sont de moins bonne
qualité que les produits de marque
nationale comparables ou équivalents et
la bonne nouvelle ou en fait la
curiosité c'est que dans certains cas
c'est la marque maison qui l'emporte
une exception dans notre échantillon de
marque maison le choix du président avec
ses biscuits le décadent le biscuit des
cadavres du Choix du Président et devenu
avec le temps la référence dans la
catégorie c'est quand même un produit de
marque maison donc son équivalent en
marque national qu'on a regardé c'est le
chips de Christie et on a regardé aussi
les produits similaires de la marque
compliment qui vient de chez
IGA et la marque sélection qui vient de
chez Métro le biscuit décadents du Choix
du Président il a la particularité
d'être celui dans mon groupe qui a une
liste d'ingrédients la plus intéressante
pas d'additif chimique dans ce produit
là du tout j'ai du chocolat j'ai envie
de dire complet donc avec la poudre et
le beurre de cacao j'apprécie aussi le
fait que le chocolat est un cacao en
fait qui est certifié de la
rainforestalion ça c'est un cas
particulier où mon produit le plus
intéressant c'est le moins cher et il
est du marque maison le moins
intéressant c'est le plus cher et il est
de marque nationale
parfois il semble que deux marques
maisons proviendraient de même
fournisseurs les listes d'ingrédients
sont
identiques c'est possible qu'il y ait
des petites différences au niveau des
assaisonnement ou du goût mais si je me
fie juste à l'étiquette c'est blanc
bonnet bonnet blanc comment on dit
exactement la même chose alors que du
côté de Cambodge la principale
différence c'est que les ingrédients
principaux c'est une base de légumes et
non pas de jus de légumes
quand les clients prennent un produit de
marque très très connu il y a un attente
évidemment nous on se doit de répliquer
ce genre de profil de goût là mais aussi
on est en mesure de se doter peut-être
d'un petit peu plus de latitude
les appels d'offres nous permettent de
voir qu'est-ce qui est disponible auprès
des fournisseurs des fabricants et de
voir aussi qui fabrique quoi pour
d'autres compétiteurs d'autres marques
on essaie
daniorer ce qu'on nous a envoyé le plus
possible tout en ayant en tête que on
veut être capable de plaire notre client
et d'offrir ces produits là à un prix
donné
[Musique]
est-ce que parfois ça peut être des
aliments moins nobles ou des partis de
l'aliment de moindre qualité de façon
générale dans presque tous les cas c'est
la même chose qu'on voit dans la marque
nationale ou dans la marque privée quand
on nous propose une tomate en conserve
comme ça évidemment on ne voit pas la
tomate entière avec sa peau et tout ça
est-ce qu'elle a besoin d'être
absolument parfaite la réponse est non
et c'est pour ça que toutes les tomates
en conserve de ce type là on voit
qu'elles sont classées Canada de choix
les concerts canadiennes se classent en
trois catégories fantaisie choix et
régulière la couleur et la grosseur des
légumes entre en ligne de compte mais ce
qui détermine la classification c'est
surtout la tendreté dans certains autres
produits comme le maïs en crème par
exemple l'on choisit un produit de
fantaisie donc niveau de qualité un peu
supérieur pourquoi notamment parce que
contrairement à la tomate qu'on voit
écraser dans la plupart des cas ici le
grain on veut le voir et on veut le
sentir ce sont tous des du fantaisie
dans cette catégorie là
dans certains cas les produits de marque
maison offrent des ingrédients et des
valeurs nutritives supérieures à la
marque nationale c'est le cas des
gaufres la marque ego se démarquent mais
pas positivement mais pas du tout
malheureusement la gaufrego encore
aujourd'hui contient beaucoup d'additifs
et d'ingrédients que je n'aime pas voir
dans un produit de déjeuner et en
particulier un produit familial voire
même enfant on parle de shorting et
d'huile de palme présent deux fois plus
tôt qu'une dans la liste d'ingrédients
de différents types de phosphates bref
ce n'est pas une les ingrédients
souhaitable gérer sans hésiter vers
celui de sélection fait par métro qui
est celui que la liste d'ingrédients la
plus simple la plus propre j'aurais
envie de dire donc sans additif
particulier et si clin d'oeil à Métro
aussi veulent améliorer encore plus il
manque de fibres en fait il manque de
fibres dans l'ensemble de la catégorie
un grand pour deux gaufres à mon sens
j'oserais même dire que c'est
inacceptable
certains consommateurs croient que la
provenance des ingrédients d'un produit
pourrait expliquer les plus bas et
mettent en doute leurs qualités les
grandes chaines sont défendent on ne
cherche pas à aller chercher des
produits d'importation pour réduire le
coût on cherche à stabiliser une chaîne
d'approvisionnement avec pour nous avoir
une stabilité au niveau du produit donc
des fournisseurs qui sont proches chez
nous qui sont faciles d'avoir les
matières premières c'est un critère
extrêmement important pour nous la
chouette produit autant au niveau de la
qualité des intrants on va chercher les
meilleurs intrants ça reste notre marque
maison c'est c'est notre c'est notre
bébé à nous fait qu'on va en être fier
pour Isabelle marquis le choix final des
consommateurs se fera sur une question
de goût il y a les différences mais les
différences pour la plupart des produits
que je me trouve à avoir analysé sont
plus des différences en termes de goût
et de texture et donc de préférence
globale du produit mais qualité globale
c'est très comparable
[Musique]